while the prime minister has now written
to rishi sunak from one resident to
another although of course the uh the
the chancellor or the former chancellor
now moved out uh back in april let's
just uh read you what that letter had to
say dear rishi says i was sorry to
receive your letter resigning from the
government you have provided outstanding
service to the country through the most
challenging period for our economy in
peacetime history in march 2020 weeks
after your appointment as chancellor we
introduced a national lockdown to
protect people from the pandemic you
acted to safeguard the economy with the
pace creativity and commitment which has
been the hallmark of your tenure the
furlough scheme conceived and
implemented in a matter of weeks
supported 11.7 million jobs from 1.3
million employers
through business loans and grants you
helped thousands of businesses to avoid
insolvency
emergency funding worth more than 140
billion pounds enabled the nhs and other
critical public services to meet the
enormous challenges we faced these
efforts
primed the economy for a rapid recovery
once the immediate dangers of the
pandemic receded at the spending review
last year you put us on track to deliver
our promises to the british people
including 20 000 police officers and 40
new hospitals we also set a clear plan
to rebuild our economy and public
services including an historic funding
settlement for the nhs and delivering
six million tutoring courses to help
pupils catch up lost learning
through all of this the statement goes
on to say you have not shied from the
tough decisions needed to repair our
public finances whilst protecting public
services and boosting economic growth
this has enabled us to provide support
to households worth 37 billion pounds as
we have faced global inflation pressures
arising from putin's brutal invasion of
ukraine
and the second page goes on and we have
begun to deliver tax cuts to families
including this week a cut to national
insurance saving the average worker 330
pounds a year i have enormously valued
your advice and deep commitment to
public service and will miss
working with you in government yours
ever it says boris johnson